Dass Aristoteles in gewisser Weise der Vater des
Determinismus ist, sollte
für diejenigen, die etwas
über seine Philosophie wissen, keine große Überraschung sein, und es wird auch
nicht überraschen, dass
er alle drei Versionen des
Determinismus entdeckte, nämlich den logischen physikalischen und den
ethischen Determinismus, den biologischen
Determinismus I  meinen das Problem, das
unter dem Titel Zukunftswahrheit diskutiert wurde,
dh die Wahrheit von Aussagen über
bestimmte kontingente Ereignisse in der
Zukunft. Der
physikalische Determinismus betrifft die
Frage, ob kausale
Konstellationen den Ausgang aller Ereignisse notwendig machen,
und der ethische Determinismus betrifft die
Frage, ob die psychologischen
Bedingungen  menschliches
Handeln bestimmen Wenn ich sage, dass
wir alle diese drei Arten von
Determinismus entdeckt haben, möchte ich nicht leugnen, dass
es frühere Diskussionen unter
bestimmten Philosophen gegeben hat, ob alle
Dinge aus Notwendigkeit geschehen oder ob
bestimmte Dinge entstehen  zufällig und
aufs Geratewohl gewisse Pre-s
Okratiker scheinen solche Ansichten gehabt zu haben, aber
wir haben keine eindeutigen Beweise
zum Beispiel für den feinkörnigen Fehler von
Demokrits Theorie der atomaren
Wechselwirkung, und obwohl
Plato den Bereich des
ewig Gleichen und Unbeweglichen
vom Bereich des Veränderlichen und Veränderlichen unterscheidet
unzuverlässig hindert ihn gerade diese Trennung daran
, die Frage aufzuwerfen, ob
gewöhnliche Dinge einschließlich menschlicher
Handlungen in irgendeiner Weise notwendig sind, und obwohl
Platon manchmal vom Gesetz des
Schicksals spricht, meint er damit nur das Schicksal,
das den Menschen nach dem Tod
je nachdem, wie sie haben, zugewiesen wird  lebten ihr Leben,
aber diese Theorien, wenn sie überhaupt als
Theorien bezeichnet werden können, waren so allgemein, dass er den
Anschein hat, dass keiner dieser Denker auch nur
die Frage aufgeworfen hat,
ob es eine ununterbrochene Reihe
von Ursachen gibt, die das Ergebnis erfordern,
und ob diese Art  Zu den kausalen
Konstellationen gehören menschliche Agenten,
Aristoteles veränderte die
Szenerie nicht nur gründlich
Ich möchte nicht auf die
Wechselwirkung zwischen den verschiedenen Arten des Determinismus eingehen, sondern auch durch die Verfeinerung dieser
Fragen, aber obwohl
er die drei Versionen des Determinismus ausgearbeitet hat, hat
ihn die Tatsache, dass die Welt
bestimmt ist, anscheinend überhaupt nicht gestört  auf diese drei Arten, denn die
Art und Weise, wie er die verschiedenen Formen des
Determinismus darstellt, zeigt, dass er
gleichzeitig keine von ihnen als wirkliches
Problem betrachtet, da meine Zeit begrenzt ist. Ich werde
insofern nur kurze Skizzen seiner Behandlung des logischen und physikalischen Determinismus geben  wie sie
die Position von Aristoteles im Allgemeinen beleuchten und sich
dann dem ethischen Determinismus zuwenden, denn
das ist das Thema dieser Konferenz
die
gleiche Bedeutung von bestimmt oder unbestimmt, nicht
bestimmt und unbestimmt in dem
Sinne, der Determinismus bedeutet,
unnötig t  Um zu sagen, dass der Begriff Determinismus
wie die meisten Ismen eine Erfindung der
frühen Neuzeit ist, wurden solche
Begriffe in der Antike nicht verwendet. Aristoteles
hat jedoch einen speziellen Begriff für
Kontingenz und einen Schamanen für das eingeführt, was
weder notwendig noch unmöglich ist, und
dieser Begriff ist überliefert  zu uns über seine
lateinischen übersetzungskontingente aber cicero
und das ist sozusagen die terminologie
in der antike
ich komme jetzt kurz zum logischen
determinismus zukunftswahrheit aber damit meine ich
die diskussion der zukunftswahrheiten und das
berühmte kapitel 9 des darstellers
zeigt das problem auch
kurz die Seeschlacht genannt, weil Aristoteles am
Beispiel einer angeblich morgen stattfindenden Seeschlacht
die Frage präzisiert, ob Aussagen
über zukünftige kontingente Ereignisse
schon vorher wahr oder falsch sind,
wenn er behauptet, dann
müssten die Ereignisse also als erledigt
gelten  wie nötig war auch diese
Frage in jenen Jahren ein heißes Thema,
als das Prinzip von by
Valen sti war  Sie werden von Logikern als eine Art heilige
Kuh angesehen, aber heutzutage werden sie nicht
mehr so behandelt. Zaube
er haben sich vielen Werten aus Holz oder
ogar Fuzzy-Logik zugewandt, und daher ist die Wertigkeit kein
uss mehr, das niemand bereit zu sein schei
t  die Keule hoch
und die Seeschlacht erneut ausfechten, wenn unser
Shuttle Aussagen über
zukünftige besondere zufällige Ereignisse von
ihrem Grundsatz akzeptiert, dass jede Aussage
entweder wahr oder falsch sein muss, dass die
Ausnahme nicht mehr als
seltsam angesehen wird,
jedenfalls wird ihm dies nicht mehr
zugeschrieben  einfachen logischen Fehler haben
wir es auf Ihrer Handreichung,
aus notwendigerweise wahrem P auf alles Gespenstische zu schließen,
daher notwendig oder notwendig, dass
nicht auf P zu vermerken ist, dass
Aristoteles im Text selbst klarstellt,
dass die Art und Weise, wie wir über Ereignisse denken oder sprechen
, keinen Einfluss hat  ihre Charakterdinge
werden nicht notwendig, nur
weil wir sie so nennen.
Aristoteles' Punkt ist eher, dass die Art und Weise, wie
wir denken, dass sie über Zustände von
a sprechen  Angelegenheiten sollten dem ontologischen
Status entsprechen, den wir ihnen zuschreiben, damit das
Problem uns betrifft und nicht die Ereignisse
selbst. Wenn wir ein Ereignis als offen betrachten
, kann es sein, dass es passieren kann oder nicht
, dann sollten wir es nicht als feststehend behandeln,
was wir tun würden  wenn wir davon ausgehen,
dass die Aussage, dass es
passieren wird, die ganze Zeit wahr gewesen sein wird,
ist nicht vereinbar mit möglicherweise oder nicht möglicherweise
nicht, um es poetischer
auszudrücken, die Annahme, dass alle Aussagen
über zukünftige Ereignisse wahr waren oder
falsch seit Anbeginn der Schöpfung bedeutet,
dass das Buch der Geschichte
zu dieser Zeit geschrieben worden sein muss Aristoteles
verwendet natürlich keine solchen poetischen Metaphern
und er glaubt sowieso nicht an die Schöpfung,
aber er ist der Meinung, dass wir
Dinge, die nur als gelten, getrennt halten sollten
wahrscheinliche Ereignisse und Dinge, die
definitiv passieren werden
zukünftige Wahrheit ist für Aristoteles eine
Frage unserer semantischen Behandlung von zukünftigen
Kontingenten, die daher leicht zu lösen ist,
aber das Problem  der zukünftigen Wahrheit
wurde später in der Geschichte wieder ein Thema,
insbesondere als sich bestimmte Philosophen und
Theologen mit der
Frage der Allwissenheit Gottes befassten, ob Gott
voraussieht und möglicherweise voraussagt, dass alle
Dinge nach Orten suchen müssen, die nicht wahr sind,
und diese Dinge dann nicht
notwendigerweise, sondern zum Glück geschehen  Für Aristoteles waren die
griechischen Götter keine Allwissenheit, also ging ihn dieses
Problem nicht an. Ich komme jetzt
zum physikalischen Determinismus. Unser Gedanke ist
ebenso kurz über das Problem der
physikalischen Notwendigkeit. Er ist überzeugt, dass
in der Natur nur bestimmte Dinge die größte
Notwendigkeit haben, während andere kontingent sind,
selbst wenn  Sie sind von der Art,
die zum größten Teil passiert. Bestimmte
Ereignisse können passieren oder auch nicht,
abhängig von den Umständen. Natürlich ist
jedes Ereignis, das passiert, notwendig,
wenn es passiert. In Aristoteles' physischer Welt gibt es keine kausalen Lücken,
aber in der
sublunaren Welt gibt es keine  Abfolgen von
Ereignissen, die im Prinzip nicht
durch Störungen unterbrochen werden können und
int  Unvorhersehbare,
weil ausserhalb des
Kontextes stehende Schlussfolgerungen nennt unser noch Total diese
Störfaktoren zufällig und
unterscheidet sie
von Naturgeschehen suzay, und solche
zufälligen Ereignisse sind nicht Gegenstand
irgendeiner Wissenschaft, weil sie
bei Aristoteles unregelmäßig und daher unvorhersehbar
sind  Universum nur der
Supermond eine Sphäre die Welt über dem Mond
ist frei von Unfällen so wie er es sah nur
die Himmelskörper bewegen sich ewig auf regelmäßigen
Bahnen Kometen und andere solche
unregelmäßigen Phänomene er lokalisierte also
auf der Südhalbkugel dies bedeutet nicht
, dass Aristoteles das akzeptierte
Existenz von unverursachten Ereignissen für
zufällige Ursachen unsere Ursache
sowie Aristoteles erklärt in der
Metaphysik epsilon22 drei zufällige
Ereignisse sind Ereignisse, die entstehen und zu sein
scheinen, aber selbst nicht die
Produkte von richtigen
Erzeugungs- oder Zerstörungsprozessen sind Sie haben den
Text auf Ihrem Handzettel  Nummer eins, die
es gibt und ich sollte das ändern
Übersetzung nicht Prinzipien, sondern erste
große erste Punkte und Ursachen, die
allgemein und zerstörbar sind, ohne
jemals im Laufe der Erzeugung
oder Zerstörung zu sein, ist offensichtlich, denn sonst werden
alle Dinge notwendig sein, da das
, was erzeugt oder
zerstört wird, eine Ursache haben muss, die  ist nicht
zufällig seine Ursache in der Natur es
gibt natürliche Abläufe, die ständig passieren, es
sei denn, etwas von außen greift ein,
was nicht Teil dieses
natürlichen Ablaufs im menschlichen Leben ist Zufälle sind
Eingriffe, die weder beabsichtigt
noch vorhersehbar sind, also werde ich ein
Zufall  Zeuge eines Autounfalls, wenn ich
zufällig zu einem ganz
anderen Zweck dort bin und Autounfälle
passieren dort nicht immer.
Unfälle sowohl in der Natur als auch im menschlichen
Leben sind nicht unverschuldet, aber sie entstehen
nicht, dh es gibt keinen
Prozess  in der Natur der Dinge,
die zu ihnen hinführt, und deshalb gibt
es keine Wissenschaft von ihnen, den Begriff
des Zufälligen  hängt im Wesentlichen von
der Teleologie des Aristoteles ab, weil er
davon ausgeht, dass natürliche Ereignisse
regelmäßig geschehen und zu ihren spezifischen
Zwecken führen, dass er Faktoren,
die solche natürlichen Ereignisabläufe unterbrechen,
als Zufälle behandeln kann, die einfach passieren. Es
gibt in der Natur keine unverursachten Ursachen für
alles, was passiert  passiert aus
Notwendigkeit, sobald es passiert, aber im
Fall von Zufällen entsteht die Notwendigkeit
erst, wenn es passiert, alle zufälligen
Ereignisse werden an bestimmten Punkten zu
notwendigen Ereignissen, wenn
nichts mehr passieren kann, sobald die
Seeschlacht begonnen hat, sie sind
ist unnötigerweise eine Seeschlacht, aber wir
müssen diese Diskussion abbrechen,
obwohl es notwendig ist, dass jeder
Mensch stirbt, ist es nicht notwendig,
dass ein bestimmtes Individuum ermordet wird
oder an einer bestimmten Krankheit stirbt, solange
bestimmte Bedingungen nicht zu einem
sicheren Sieg führen  vielleicht war er einfach der
falsche am falschen ort, wie wir
oft sagen, so dass er zum
acci-opfer wurde  Zahn, aber das wäre natürlich
nicht so gewesen, wenn die Mörder geplant
hätten, ihn zu schnappen, aber angesichts der
Möglichkeit von Zufällen gibt es keine
ununterbrechbare Reihe von Ursachen
vom Anbeginn der Schöpfung, die zu
diesem Ereignis führen, und das ist der Grund, warum ich
wiederherstelle  Die Behauptung, dass es erste
Anfänge von ersten Sternen gibt, die
keine weiteren eigentlichen Anfänge als
Ursache haben, so dass diese besondere Abfolge von
Ereignissen die ganze Zeit über notwendig war, dass
Deterministen anerkannt wurden, dass solche
teleologischen Unterscheidungen
nicht bestehen, werden von Aristoteles' Erklärung natürlich nicht beeindruckt sein,
sie werden es tun  Einwand, dass
unvorhersehbare Ereignisse nur deswegen so sind, weil
uns nicht alles bekannt ist. Aristoteles
würde natürlich entgegnen, dass nur bestimmte
Arten von Ereignissen grundsätzlich erkennbar sind
und dass viele
Möglichkeiten nicht unter den Adligen liegen, sondern rigorose
Deterministen den gesamten
Zustand umfassen werden  das Universum von einem Moment auf
den anderen auf dem Konto und lassen sich
um keine Fähigkeit kümmern  y aber in diesem Fall
passiert alles, sogar das unwahrscheinlichste Ereignis notwendigerweise, aber das bedeutet, dass
die Unterscheidung zwischen natürlichen und nicht
natürlichen Ereignissen
aufgegeben werden muss, aber hier
verlassen wir die Debatte über die physikalische
Notwendigkeit und wenden uns uns zu  Der dritte und letzte
und interessanteste Punkt zum ethischen
Determinismus Leser der nikomachischen
Ethik mögen sich zunächst fragen, warum die Ethik
in diese Diskussion einbezogen werden sollte, wenn man bedenkt
, dass Aristoteles
mit einer Warnung beginnt, von der Ethik nicht
die gleiche Genauigkeit wie von der
Mathematik zu erwarten  denn
in ethischen Dingen gibt es viele Schwankungen, so dass
man sich mit Prämissen begnügen sollte
, die nur grob und in Umrissen die Wahrheit wiedergeben, und
gleichartige Konsequenzen in der Ethik zu erwarten hat, es gibt keine
strengen Gebote, sondern gelten nur
zum größten Teil  Angesichts dieses Prinzips
der Ungewissheit,
warum beinhalten Ethik und Diskussionen über den
Determinismus Aristoteles' Warnung vor der
Erwartung von Pre  Die oft missverstandene Meinungsbildung in der Ethik
bedeutet nicht, dass es den
Grundbegriffen und Prinzipien der Ethik
an Präzision mangelt, sondern nur, dass
es keine präzisen allgemeinen Regeln darüber gibt,
was bei bestimmten Handlungen richtig und falsch ist,
weil Anpassungen an die besonderen Umstände vorgenommen werden müssen
nämlich
wer der Agent ist und in welcher Beziehung
er zu der von seiner Handlung betroffenen Person steht
der Moment der Handlung die
verfügbaren Mittel usw. Aristoteles
vergleicht die Situation eines Agenten in der
Ethik mit der eines Kapitäns zur See und eines
Arztes in  Medizin, obwohl es
allgemeine Regeln gibt, müssen sie
natürlich an die jeweilige Situation
angepasst werden, wie im Fall eines schweren Sturms oder im Fall eines bestimmten Patienten in einem kritischen Zustand, aber diese Unsicherheit
darüber, was in einer bestimmten Situation richtig oder falsch ist
, legt dies nahe  dem
Agenten steht es frei, diese Anpassungen vorzunehmen,
daher mag sich jemand fragen, warum es in
Arist eine Frage zu Freiheit und
Determinismus geben sollte  otle's ethics for
abgesehen von der Ungewissheit
menschlicher Handlungen hat Aristoteles nicht
einmal eine passende Terminologie Freiheitslegierung
Surya wird nur im politischen
Sinne von freier Geburt und Autonomie verwendet und
notorisch gab es im griechischen
Altgriechisch auch keinen Begriff, der ein Testament
als
ein bezeichnete  Unabhängige psychologische Fakultät
Stattdessen verwendet Aristoteles
in seiner Erörterung menschlicher Handlungen,
die uns betreffen, einen anderen Begriff, nämlich ob und unter
welchen Bedingungen unsere Handlungen an uns liegen,
wenn er meint, und dies ist der Begriff
, der später in den jahrhundertelangen Debatten
über Freiheit und Freiheit verwendet wurde  Determinismus zwischen
den kartentragenden Deterministen der Stoiker
und ihren Gegnern, den
Epikureern, den Peripatetikern und natürlich
auch den Skeptikern, wenn Aristoteles
als der Vater dieser Debatte behandelt wird
, liegt das daran, dass es in der nikomachischen
Ethik sehr viel um
Bedingungen geht, unter denen unsere  handlungen
obliegen uns sie müssen freiwillig sein d.h.
begangen mit kenntnis der
zirk  unter Umständen und ohne Zwang durch
äußere Gewalt, außerdem müssen
sie unserer eigenen Überlegung
und Wahl entsprechen und ihr Ziel oder Zweck
muss unseren Wünschen entsprechen, all dies
wird mit großer Sorgfalt und ziemlich
ausführlich in der Ethikkommission in
Buch 3 so aufgezeigt  Warum sollte es ein Problem
mit dem Determinismus geben, denn es scheint
ganz klar, dass unsere Handlungen in dem Sinne von uns abhängig sind,
dass wir sie entweder
tun oder lassen können, solange es
keinen äußeren Zwang gibt oder wir uns
nicht über bestimmte Tatsachen im Klaren sind
es gibt jedoch ein Problem, ob
menschliches Handeln nach Aristoteles
determiniert ist, wenn es ein Problem gibt, dann
liegt es in der Frage, ob menschliches
Handeln durch den Charakter des Handelnden bestimmt ist
, denn Aristoteles
bestreitet dies nicht nur nicht, es ist
eines seiner Hauptanliegen  Ethik nämlich,
durch die richtige Art der
Gewöhnungshilfe frühzeitig dafür zu sorgen, dass Menschen
eine feste Veranlagung erwerben, das
Richtige zu tun  Die richtigen
Umstände zu finden und die falschen zu vermeiden,
denn genau das werden
Menschen nicht können, die sich die falschen Charakterpositionen angeeignet haben,
daher ist die
Bezeichnung der richtigen moralischen
Erziehung das Kennzeichen der aristotelischen Ethik,
es geht nicht nur um deren Tugenden
Charakter, der durch
adäquate Gewöhnung und Ausbildung erworben wird es geht
auch um den Erwerb der
praktischen Vernunft von Öfen wie dieser
Erwerb funktioniert ist einer der zentralen
Punkte der Ethik des Aristoteles Gewöhnung
ist nicht so einfach wie es klingt nur
bedeutet nicht durch Drill erworbene Gewohnheiten
Messer und Gabeln zu benutzen oder zu
schwimmen oder Fahrrad zu fahren, statt dessen
geht es ihm um die Aneignung der
richtigen emotionalen Einstellung und des
richtigen praktischen Denkens, wenn es darum geht
, Entscheidungen zu treffen, wie das funktioniert,
füllt einen großen Teil der nikomachischen
Ethik aus und damit auch mich  Ich kann hier nicht auf
Details eingehen, es genügt zu sagen, dass
wir durch unseren Charakter t bestimmt sind  as
die Tatsache, dass wir durch unseren Charakter bestimmt sind,
von Aristoteles nicht als Problem angesehen wird, ist vielmehr der
eigentliche Gedanke und das Ziel seiner Ethik, denn darum
geht es bei der moralischen Erziehung, um das moralisch Wohlergehen
eines Menschen zu gewährleisten  wird unter
den richtigen Umständen das Richtige tun unsere Geschichte würde
daher sicherlich die Frage
rätseln, ob der moralisch richtig
gebrachte Mensch nicht umhin kann, das
Richtige für ihn zu tun, es ist keine mathematische
Frage, automatisch
das Richtige zu tun oder zu denken, was die Agenten
noch haben  ihre moralischen und
intellektuellen Fähigkeiten einzusetzen, um
die richtige Entscheidung über die richtige
Lösung zu treffen, aber sie werden dies tun, es sei denn,
etwas stört sie. Wenn also bei Aristoteles alles in Ordnung ist,
warum sollte es ein
Problem mit dem ethischen Determinismus geben,
gibt es einen Punkt in der nikomachischen
Ethik, wo  Aristoteles stellt ausdrücklich
die Frage, ob wir
für unseren eigenen Charakter und damit für
unser eigenes Handeln überhaupt verantwortlich sind  Unmittelbar
nach
Abschluss des allgemeinen Arguments, dass unser
Charakter an uns hängt
und die nikomachischen Ethikbücher
Kapitel 5 lesen, erhebt er tatsächlich zwei
Einwände, den ersten
wischt er schnell beiseite, während er
bezüglich des zweiten Einwands etwas zu zögern scheint,
also lassen Sie uns  werfen sie einen kurzen blick auf
beide einwände und auf die art und
weise, wie aristoteles sie regelt. der erste einwand
greift unsere standeskonstante spannung auf, dass
man seinen charakter selbst bestimmen muss,
weil wir nicht nur
aktiv zu seiner erwerbung beitragen, sondern uns
auch darum kümmern müssen  und
unser hypothetischer Einwand für den Dienst lautet
wie folgt, dass zwei erforderlich sind, aber vielleicht ist
jemand die Art von Mann, der sich nicht
kümmert, und er weist diesen Einwand
schnell mit der Begründung zurück, dass Nachlässigkeit
auch eine erworbene Eigenschaft ist, er argumentiert in
diesem Fall, dass man sie nicht erwirbt
seine moralischen Gewohnheiten durch ein träges Leben,
ohne sich dessen bewusst zu sein, denn
nur ein Dummkopf würde die
Folgen einer bestimmten Lebensweise nicht kennen
Leben aber wenn man weiß, dass man
sozusagen auf einem schiefen Abhang ist, bedeutet das,
dass man seinen moralischen
Verfall freiwillig in Kauf nimmt und Aristoteles eine
solche Sorglosigkeit mit dem
Erwerb einer Krankheit des Körpers vergleicht, durch
schlechtes Leben wird sich ein solcher erworbener schlechter
Zustand herausstellen  später irrelevant sein,
auch wenn die Person dies dann
wünschen sollte,
das ist der Text zur zweiten Hälfte. In diesem
Fall wurde ihm nämlich zunächst
ermöglicht, nicht krank zu sein, aber nicht jetzt, wenn er
seine Chance vertan hat, genau wie wenn
Sie möchten  ein steinernes Tor, es ist zu
spät, es wiederzuerlangen, aber es
stand Ihnen frei, es nicht zu werfen,
da das bewegende Prinzip in Ihnen so
treu war, dem ungerechten und
zügellosen Mann, dass es am Anfang offen war, es
nicht zu tun  Männer dieser Art werden
und so sind sie freiwillig ungerechte und
zügellose Männer,
aber jetzt, wo sie es geworden sind, ist es
nicht möglich, dass sie es nicht
sind. Wo der Anfang dieses
rutschigen Abhangs ist, ist natürlich eine gute
Frage  Da mag man sich fragen, ob man
nicht immer entweder zu jung oder zu alt ist
, um den Anfang selbst in der Hand zu haben,
zunächst ist man doch in der
Hand der Eltern und Lehrer und hat sich
später schlechte Angewohnheiten angeeignet, so
dass man nicht kann  Sie nicht mehr loswerden,
aber Aristoteles scheint zu denken, dass er sonst
nach dem Prinzip zu gehen scheint, dass die
Vernunft etwa im Alter von 14 Jahren einsetzt, damit
man die Werte der Welt versteht
und sie annehmen oder ablehnen kann, bei denen niemand
ein eingefleischter Lügner oder Krimineller ist  dieses
Alter, aber was mit jemandem passiert, der
in einer schlechten Familie oder in einer Diebesbande aufwächst,
ist eine andere Sache, aber ich werde nicht weiter
darauf eingehen, dass Aristoteles hier ganz
bewusst den Grundsatz befürwortet,
dass ein bestimmtes auf einer bestimmten Stufe der
eigenen Entwicklung es tatsächlich ist  nicht
mehr an uns liegt, wie wir moralisch
sind und das gilt auch für unsere
jeweiligen Entscheidungen und Handlungen, dass
wir von unserem Charakter zum
Guten oder Schlechten bestimmt werden, ist für Aristoteles eher
das zentrale p  ist seine Ethik und
wie gesagt sein Markenzeichen, denn seiner Meinung nach reicht das
Wissen um das richtige Ziel allein nicht
aus, man muss die richtigen
emotionalen Dispositionen mit der richtigen
Art von Verlangen haben, um das
richtige Ziel anzustreben und das und das  die die
richtigen Entscheidungen treffen,
um dieses Ziel zu erreichen, deshalb hat
Aristoteles so viel Wert auf Gewöhnung und
Bildung gelegt, was er immer wieder in einer
Art Mantra-ähnlichen Formulierung wiederholt, dann muss
man daran gewöhnt sein, nicht nur so zu handeln, wie man sollte
die Person, die man sollte, wenn
man sollte, und so weiter, und die gleichen
Chancen galten auch für die eigenen Gefühle auf dem
Weg a. Wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen, uns so zu
fühlen, wie wir mit den
Menschen sprechen sollten, wie wir
sollten  und so weiter Aristoteles spricht oft so,
als ob die Emotionen und Handlungen auf einer
Macht liegen, die gleichberechtigte Partner sind,
aber Reflexion zeigt, warum dies nicht
so sein kann, während Überlegung und Wahl
Handlungen wollen, wie man handelt,
wem gegenüber man handelt und so weiter  dass
Handlungen gewählt werden, man wählt nicht
seine Gefühle, sie werden durch einen Eindruck provoziert,
wie man Pathos
in diesem Sinne übersetzen könnte, weil Aristoteles
in seiner Ethik nicht viel über die
Emotionen und die jeweilige Eindrucksfähigkeit
sagt, seine Lehre über die Art und Weise, wie
Menschen beeindruckt werden  und konditioniert,
bestimmte Dinge auf bestimmte Weise zu begehren,
bleibt weniger transparent, als man es
sich in der nikomachischen Ethik wünschen mag, er
zählt nur die Emotionen auf, die er im
Sinn hat, und zwar mit Emotionen Ich meine Appetit Zorn
Angst Vertrauen Neid Freude Liebe Hass
Sehnsucht Wettbewerb Mitleid
und überhaupt die Gefühle
die von Freude und Schmerz begleitet werden, da
die Emotionen Eindrücke auf dem
nicht rationalen Weg der Seele sind, von denen gesagt wird,
dass sie unter der Führung der Vernunft stehen. Es mag den
Anschein haben, dass es eine Art
Arbeitsteilung zwischen der passiven
Eindrucksfähigkeit und der aktiven Entscheidung gibt, wie es geht
Zumindest ist das der Auftritt, den
Aristoteles in den nikomachischen
Ethikbüchern 2 & 3 gibt, wo handeln Er behandelt
Emotionen und Handlungen, als wären sie ein
Kumpel und arbeitet Hand in Hand. Dass die
Dinge nicht so einfach sind, wird deutlich, wenn wir
uns die Definition der verschiedenen Arten
von Emotionen in der Rhetorik ansehen, denn es stellt sich
heraus, dass die reifen Emotionen so sind
kognitiv informierte Antworten auf eine
bestimmte Situation sprechen Die Komplexität der
emotionalen Reaktion wird zum
Beispiel in der Definition von Wut in der
Rhetorik deutlich - - Sie haben das auf der Hand
Text 3 Wut kann als ein
von Schmerz begleiteter Wunsch nach Rache für eine
scheinbare Rache definiert werden  Leicht aus den Händen von
Männern, die keinen Ruf haben, sich selbst oder seine Freunde zu rutschen
, das schließt die Familie ein, also gibt es
eine diagnostische Fähigkeit und ein Urteilsvermögen,
das bei solchen Gefühlen angewendet wird, aber es kommt noch
mehr, das ist der Rest von t3, es
muss gefühlt werden, weil  der andere
ihm oder einem seiner freunde etwas angetan hat oder antun wollte,
es muss immer
eine gewisse lust dabei sein,
die aus der erwartung auf
rache dafür entsteht  Es ist angenehm zu denken, dass
Sie das erreichen werden, was Sie anstreben, und
niemand das anstrebt, was er glaubt, nicht
erreichen zu können, also sind dies hochtrainierte
Gefühle, sie haben propositionalen Inhalt,
aber sie bewerten nicht nur die Art der
Verletzung, sondern auch die Zufriedenheit, die damit verbunden ist
zu erwarten, und solche Emotionen sind
eindeutig nicht die rohen Gefühle, die wir
mit kleinen Kindern und Tieren teilen.
Gefühle sind dann viel komplexer als
die Diskussion in der Ethik
zunächst vermuten lässt. Dies ist erwähnenswert, denn
es erklärt, was Aristoteles meint, wenn er
sagt  Sie enden oder zielen ab. Der Tellus einer
Handlung wird durch den eigenen Charakter
zum Besseren oder Schlechteren bestimmt, denn es ist der Wunsch, eine
Art Verlangen, das das Ende bestimmt.
Leider spricht Aristoteles
in dem kurzen Kapitel, das
ein Lehrer ihm widmet, nicht sehr ausdrücklich über Wünsche, aber er
erklärt, dass Wünsche durch das verursacht werden, was
einem bestimmten Menschen gut erscheint,
ob es wirklich so ist oder nur
scheinbar, damit der gute Mensch die
richtigen Eindrücke hat  sionen und die Bösen die
Falschen Mystiker Text für die Guten
urteilt Queeny über jede Klasse von
Dingen richtig und in jedem Fall
erscheint ihm die Wahrheit, denn jeder
Charakterzustand hat seinen eigenen edlen und angenehmen
Gegenstand und vielleicht unterscheidet sich der Gute
von anderen am meisten  Indem die
Wahrheit in jedem Ding sozusagen die
Norm eines Maßstabs von ihnen ist, ist es
erwähnenswert, dass Aristoteles nicht sagt, dass
der Gegenstand der Wahl eine Frage der
Wahl ist, sondern sich auf
die Handlung bezieht
, die zu diesem Zweck ausgeführt wird  der zweck selbst wird
durch den eindruck bestimmt, den man
vom erstrebenswerten hat, und diese
eindrücke hängen auch von den
erworbenen veranlagungen ab. ich werde
all
diese informationen ausschütten, weil klar wird
, dass die bestimmung der eigenen
handlungen  soweit das Ziel oder der
Zweck nicht nur eine Sache der rationalen
Wahl, sondern auch eine Frage des
halbrationalen Charakters ist, sind es keine rohen
Gefühle, aber sie enthalten  In dem
Eindruck, was an einem Ende gut ist und
deshalb möchte ich Wunsch nicht als
rationales Verlangen bezeichnen, wie es viele Interpreten tun,
sondern als rational informiertes Verlangen, warum ist das
alles so wichtig? Es ist so, weil es
direkt mit unserem Status zusammenhängt
dass unser Charakter an uns liegt
, ist ein Einwand, der schwerwiegender ist als die
ersten Einwände gegen den Menschen, der so ist
, dass er sich nicht um unsere Gesamtheit kümmert,
erkennt dort in einer Weise an, dass
Menschen nicht alle gleich geboren werden und nicht
alle die gleiche Chance haben
er gibt dies als Antwort auf ein
Argument insofern in drei neuen Comics
in über drei fünf wieder zu und wir wissen nicht,
ob es Aristoteles dort
um einen tatsächlichen Einwand eines Gegners geht
oder ob es sich um einen selbst
fabrizierten Einwand von
Aristoteles handelt  er greift die
überlegung auf, dass jeder das tut, was er für das
beste hält und dass es darauf ankommt,
welchen eindruck er vom besten hat
das ist text 5 und das zielen am ende
ist nicht selbsterwählt, sondern ein Merkmal, sondern man
muss gleichsam mit einem Auge geboren sein
, um richtig zu urteilen und
das wahrhaft Gute zu wählen, und
wer damit gut ausgestattet ist, der ist von der Natur gut begabt, denn
es ist das Größte und Höchste  edel
und wir können nicht von einem anderen bekommen oder lernen,
sondern müssen es so haben, wie es
für uns bei der Geburt war, und damit gut ausgestattet
zu sein, wird perfekt und
wahrhaftig von natürlicher Begabung sein, wenn
dies wahr ist, wie werden Sie dann mehr werden
freiwillig als Laster tun beide Menschen gleichermaßen
das Gute und das Schlechte, das Ende
scheint von Natur aus festgesetzt zu sein oder wie auch immer es sein mag,
und indem er alles andere
darauf bezieht, wird dieser Mann tun, was Männer tun werden, was
auch immer sie tun, was unsere Geschichte tun
sollte  Diesen Einwand aufzugreifen, ist an
sich schon sehr seltsam, denn viel früher in
der nikomachischen Ethik hat er
die Möglichkeit abgelehnt, dass Menschen von
Natur aus gut oder schlecht sind, entweder als eine Art
Geschenk der Götter oder durch Zufall, aber das
ist nicht das Einzige, was so ist  seltsam
um  wie
Aristoteles mit seinem Einwand umgeht, denn
er weist ihn in seinen weiteren Ausführungen nicht ohne
Weiteres zurück, sondern lässt die
Frage offen, ob das Ziel oder der Zweck
einem Menschen von Natur aus gut oder schlecht erscheint,
sondern konzentriert sich nur
darauf, dass die Wahl des  Das bedeutet,
dass es dem Agenten obliegt,
als Argument, dass seine
unsere Handlungen an ihm liegen, aber in gewisser
Weise scheint er hier zuzugeben, dass Agenten
nur eine verminderte Art von Verantwortung
haben, die sechs sechs wenn dann dauert  Wie
behauptet wird, sind die Tugenden freiwillig, denn
wir sind selbst irgendwie
Mitursachen unseres Charakterzustands,
und indem wir Tausende einer bestimmten
Art sind, setzen wir das Ende so, und so werden auch
die Laster freiwillig sein, denn
dasselbe gilt  Von ihnen scheint dies ein
starkes Zugeständnis an die Vorstellung zu sein, dass
es natürliche Prädispositionen in
Bezug auf das gibt, was Sie raten, und in dieser
Art von Zugeständnissen, die wir sonst
nirgendwo in Aristoteles' Ethik finden
Er erwähnt weder ein natürliches
Ich für das, was ein guter Zweck ist, noch
beschränkt er die Verantwortung für die
Darstellung des eigenen Charakters auf
sogenannte
Rufmenschen, da nur Mitursachen dafür sind, dass das Wort
bald Ideen nirgendwo anders in
der Ethik und anderswo verwendet wird und
Aristoteles benennt normalerweise notwendige, aber nicht
hinreichende Bedingungen, und ich muss hinzufügen, dass
in juristischen Diskussionen davon ausgegangen wird, dass Ideen ein
Komplize eines Verbrechens sind. Diese
Diskussion über ein natürliches Auge und
Mitverantwortung kommt erst ganz am
Ende von Aristoteles allgemeiner Diskussion
über Charaktertugenden  bevor er in
die Diskussion der einzelnen Arten
einsteigt, mag er das Gefühl haben, dass das
Zugeständnis solcher einschränkenden Bedingungen, auch wenn
es für seine Gesamttheorie nicht von großer Bedeutung war
, darüber hinaus
Aristoteles zuvor in seiner allgemeinen
Diskussion über den Begriff
der Charaktertugend das erwähnt hat  Menschen können sich daher in
ihren natürlichen ziemlich positiven
Veranlagungen Gedanken eher von den
anderen unterscheiden  gibt den
Rat, dass man sie nach hinten gebeugt führen würde
, um diese schlechten Veranlagungen zu korrigieren,
außerdem erwähnt er viel später
in seiner Ethik, dass es
natürliche Tugenden von BHs an gibt, aber dass
diese nicht natürlichen Tugenden trainiert werden müssen,
weil Menschen ohne solches Training daran
gebunden sind  schiefgehen, so dass Aristoteles in gewisser Weise
zugibt, dass einige Menschen von Natur aus
bessere Karten haben, als
andere zu sagen, aber er existiert immer noch, dass viel
davon abhängt, was Sie mit Ihren Waden tun
, dass es klar ist, dass
Aristoteles nicht ewig betrachtet  hat
ethischen Determinismus als negatives,
sondern als positives und sogar als
notwendiges Merkmal menschlicher
Verantwortung gesehen, denn er ist die einzige
Garantie menschlicher Zuverlässigkeit, ohne
moralische Gewöhnung würden wir willkürlich handeln,
und das ist keine
positive Bedingung menschlichen Lebens und ist es auch nicht
Was die Leute normalerweise im Sinn haben, wenn
sie die Frage nach dem freien Willen oder
irgendetwas von uns aufwerfen, halten sie normalerweise
nicht für unvorhersehbar  Die Menschen,
die sich unberechenbar oder skurril verhalten, gelten als
besonders frei, sondern eher als Freaks.
Aristoteles ist sich durchaus bewusst,
dass es Menschen gibt, die einige
natürliche Mängel haben. Er spricht nicht
nur von krankhaften Zuständen und Wahnsinn, sondern auch von
Zwangszuständen. Seine Beispiele sind keine
Kleptomanen oder  Pyromane, sondern
zwanghaftes Nägelkauen oder
Haare zupfen, aber abgesehen von diesen krankhaften
Zuständen hält er den Menschen für
moralisch formbar durch die richtige
Erziehung und natürlich durch die falsche
Erziehung - aber nicht
nur solche Unzulänglichkeiten der Natur sind das
sind ein Hindernis für die richtige moralische
Entwicklung, wie ich zuvor sagte.
Aristoteles gibt zu, dass einige Menschen
bessere Karten haben als andere und es nicht
immer an ihnen liegt, dies
durch ein gutes Ausspielen ihrer Karten auszugleichen, wie Aristoteles
an einer Stelle sagt, eine Person, die sehr arm ist
hässlich von einer schlechten familie und ohne freunde
wird wahrscheinlich kein glückliches leben führen eine
gewisse menge an externen gütern ist
nicht nur für b notwendig  Richtig handeln zu können,
sondern auch für den
Erwerb der Tugenden, denn das
setzt voraus,
von früh an richtig tätig zu sein Aristoteles
bestreitet also nicht, dass es das gibt, was
Bernard Williams moralisches Glück
in Bezug auf die eigene moralische Entwicklung genannt hat,
aber  das wird Aristoteles
sowieso nicht leugnen nicht alles hängt von
uns ab und bestimmte externe Faktoren sind
eindeutig nicht Aristoteles sagt einmal, man
muss das Beste aus dem machen, was man hat, nur ein
Schuhmacher muss das Beste aus dem Leder machen, das
er hat  muss arbeiten
und ein General muss das Beste aus
der Art von Armee machen, die er zufällig hat, so dass
ethischer Determinismus, dass jeder Weg,
in Übereinstimmung mit dem eigenen moralischen und
intellektuellen Potenzial zu handeln, seine
Grenzen hat, aber Aristoteles scheint sich darüber
keine Sorgen zu machen  Diese Tatsache
beunruhigte ihn auch nicht der ethische Determinismus als solcher,
sobald wir eine Persönlichkeit erworben haben, werden
wir immer in gleicher Weise handeln, es
sei denn, ein äußerer oder innerer Faktor
hindert uns daran  Ich tue dies, aber wie gesagt,
er betrachtet dies als einen positiven Faktor, nicht
als einen Faktor, der
unser Handeln in einem solchen Fall einschränkt, der immer noch von unserer
Überlegung und Entscheidung abhängt. Aristoteles war
außerdem nicht besorgt über die
Möglichkeit, dass wir eine Maschine haben  in
unserem Kopf, deren Arbeit wir nicht ganz
verstehen, die aber bestimmt, was wir
tun, wie die Illustration
auf dem Flyer dieser Konferenz suggeriert, denn
Aristoteles betrachtete das Gehirn nicht als
das Organ des Denkens, sondern hielt es nicht
für das erforderliche Denken  Jedes physische
Organ, das Gehirn, ist für
Aristoteles nur ein Kühlgerät, und obwohl er
das Herz als Zentrum unseres
bewussten Prozesses behandelt, ist es weder eine
Denkmaschine noch ethischer Determinismus, und
Aristoteles meint nur, dass Menschen
durch ihre selbsterworbene
Moral bestimmt werden  Persönlichkeit und das ist in seinen
Augen kein negativer, sondern ein positiver Fakt,
weil er Verlässlichkeit
bei der Bootcut-Person und zumindest
Berechenbarkeit bei der c verspricht  In Anbetracht des
Bösen handelten gute Menschen anders
als nach ihren Wünschen.
Natürlich könnten sie, aber
sie müssten Gründe für solche
Abweichungen haben,
obwohl Aristoteles
Konflikte nicht ausführlich diskutiert,
ihre Existenz anerkennt und nicht geht  überhaupt
in ein Opfer zu verwandeln, damit er nicht
all unsere kleinen Probleme diskutiert, die die
Philosophen heutzutage so sehr stören, dass
es für ihn keine strikte
Vorhersagbarkeit dessen gibt, was eine Person tun wird,
und Aristoteles sagt nie, dass eine moralisch
bedingte Person notwendigerweise tun wird,
was sie tut
Die Ausfälle, über die Aristoteles spricht,
betreffen unsere moralischen Einsichten, nämlich wie
man sich gegenüber der Person verhalten sollte, zu der man zu dem Zweck handeln sollte, zu dem man sollte
Person
akzeptiert hat und das zumindest in einer guten
Gemeinschaft allgemein akzeptiert wird, hier ist
kein Zwang gemeint, sondern nur  Die
Anerkennung dessen, was
alles in allem das Richtige ist,
erklärt, wo Aristoteles
den Menschen in gewissem Maße als
von seiner Persönlichkeit bestimmt betrachtet und warum er dies
politisch als eine gute Sache ansieht,
als eine notwendige Sache, wenn eine
Gemeinschaft sein soll  vier
Menschen müssen sich aufeinander verlassen
können und das bedeutet, dass sie als
Ganzes charakterlich handeln erst in der
späteren Antike wurde der moralische
Determinismus als Problem gesehen, nachdem die
Stoiker den Einsatz erhöht hatten
nicht nur Physikalisten in dem Sinne, dass
alles, was passiert, physikalische
Ursachen hat und dass dieselben Ursachen
immer dieselben Wirkungen haben, sondern sie gingen auch
davon aus, dass es allgemeine kosmische
Gesetze gibt, die den Ausgang von
allem zwangsläufig bestimmen, so dass es
von Anbeginn an notwendig gewesen wäre  Schöpfung
darüber, dass Ödipus seinen Vater töten
und seine Mutter heiraten würde, gab es von da
an einen unaufhörlichen Kampf zwischen
Deterministen und in  Deterministen ein
Kampf, der stark verschärft wurde, als
Gottes Wille ein zusätzlicher Faktor in der
Auseinandersetzung wurde, aber von all dem wusste unser Schwert
nichts, er betrachtete es als unsere Sache, wie wir
uns verhalten sollten, und in geringerem
Maße behandelte er es als unsere Sache
Menschen, als die wir uns
herausstellen werden, und deshalb macht er die Menschen
für ihre eigenen Taten verantwortlich